[Music]
absolutely
[Music]
[Music]
oh what a lad now since the name of the
podcast is called what a lad i'm often
asked why have i just had rugby lads on
well not anymore i'm branching out and
i've gone straight to the top with one
of new zealand's best lads he's arguably
new zealand's top comedian and he's done
it all he's won the billy t award for
comedy he's been the face of tv in new
zealand and the voice of radio in new
zealand he's also been voted the sexiest
man in new zealand in 2014
he's also had his own song make the
charts reaching number two in new
zealand and of course he now has his
very own tv show new zealand today which
is one of the great laughs it is of
course nelson's finest guy williams so
good to be here bro so good to be here
and there were so many things about the
intro that was so wrong
i'm so excited you said one of new
zealand's top or arguably new zealand's
top come in you can't argue that at all
you'd go okay well if you don't count
the the ones who have passed away billy
t rop um john clark then you go fly the
concords rose matafeo you know ursula
carlson uh die henwood the list is so
long i'm like 45 down
jimmy jackson on facebook i'm so far
down
wait it's someone's opinion i've i had
it a lot lots of people said you're the
best comedian in new zealand yeah and a
lot of people say i'm the worst as well
that's
that'd be great interesting he's the
arguably the worst comedian in new
zealand let's go
but i'm so stoked to be here man mate
stoke to have you on it's great to have
someone a little bit different i mean a
comedian uh someone who's funny i guess
no offense but have you not had a woman
on this podcast
it is called it is called what a ladder
you've done a hundred episodes you can
interview one woman a woman can be a
land can they what is this what is this
like future dystopia where women don't
exist in this world
no it is in the pipeline to be fair
you have stitched yourself up with the
title what a lad but yeah well i'm sure
it will be it'll be fine yeah you know
we'll get there i'm sure and it's gonna
probably absolutely blow up isn't it
when the when the first woman does come
on what a lad it's going to be well no
based on this like weird like in-cell
following you've probably got
now sorry the followers you're the best
um uh
it'll probably be your worst ever rating
one because we're inherently sexist in
society but um you'll you know times are
changing slowly and we're moving forward
hopefully to a brighter tomorrow or
based on the way america's going we're
heading backwards at a rate of knots
[Laughter]
we will see but anyway mate you heard
the jingle what'd you think of the
jingle that was so good did you sing
that who sung that no that was actually
um alex hamer yeah i put it onto the
instagram and someone decided to make
that that's so good i mean whoever owns
the rights that music will sue your ass
as soon as you get big enough but um
until then
rock that song rock that song get on you
man mate it's good to get an opinion
obviously from someone who's been right
up there on the new zealand chart i'm
one of the best comedians in new zealand
according to this podcast
and musicians i mean the song the pigeon
song
my brother's talented and i was most of
my accomplishments were just like wacky
things we did on radio so the what you
said was sexist man and people would
listen to that and go how is that a
thing i wasn't really sexist man i was
more best at voting for himself
thousands of times on the internet the
tv guide it was like a popularity
contest and i got um all the listeners
to the radio station to um to vote for
me that's how i did that i basically
rigged her i beat tj from short street
one of the um one of the sexiest dudes
of all time also a bit of a douche but
uh sexy dude so i was stoked to beat him
yeah um and well you obviously beat
sunny bear as well is that sort of how
the beef started beasts
i love sonny bill pill always hit me up
there's a few things people always talk
with me about
my interview with the mob and sonny bill
is the one that people always talk about
and i can i say for the record i love
sonny bill and think he genuinely is the
best yeah there's so many things that
are good about sonny bill and the way i
met him was because he was literally the
best dude i would go to the all blacks
gentlemen ben i was on a show called
john and ben they would send me to all
blacks press conferences we weren't
allowed to be there i'd have no
credentials i'd get in trouble with the
bosses every time and there's a few
people who are really nice to me one was
izzy dagg he was the best guy like he
was just like so supportive and like
would come and you know give me a few
answers and the other was sonny bill and
sonny bill took it to another level not
only would he ask answer my questions he
would give me like gold like and i was
interviewing james macony i remember
from uh crow goes wild behind the scenes
and um out of nowhere sunnyvale came and
just put me in a headlock you know and
instantly that like made my segment
because it was like
sonny bill who was like the god of new
zealand at the time yeah um was like
playing along and like having a laugh
and i was so appreciative of that and he
literally made my career my career only
like took off from there
and then um
yeah i mocked him a few times
went too far i peeved him off and i
think he was two people he just like
blocked me on twitter because he was
sick of me you know sick of hearing
about me basically yeah and then i you
know i said some things that i maybe
shouldn't have he maybe was a bit too
head problem that he was a bit too
sensitive too yeah and um from there it
just went bad and i feel bad because
people think that like i hate on sonny
sunnybrook because a lot of people do
hate on them um i mean there's i'd love
to get into that but um i don't hate
sunny build or i genuinely love the guy
and owe him a lot because he helped make
my career man what a lovely lovely dude
and um i stalked him to japan twice the
first time he was stoked to see me the
second time he was just like bro
why are you here
why get a life like is there nothing
else going in your career and the answer
sunny is no there is nothing else going
on in my career but he was he was he was
um cordial he was great both times was
one of the like the best things i've
ever done plus i got to go to japan yeah
amazing and uh i'd love to ask you about
japan but i'd love to say this about
sunny as well like what he's done for
like
the muslim community in new zealand is
genuinely amazing people don't know
about that but like i have friends um
who are muslim in auckland and they like
sonny bill is their mate kind of thing
and it is a big deal when you consider
how much like islamophobia is in new
zealand and how much we don't understand
that religion i remember he became a
professional rugby player we switched
from league people were already hating
him on the there but then um his
religion became like a big thing because
they're like oh because of uh fasting
and stuff like that yeah and instead of
like talking to um islamic muslim people
and trying to learn about the religion
people just speculated that he wouldn't
be able to do it and he proved everyone
wrong you know like he's been a great
contributor to new zealand i think he
won two world cups right yeah did a few
yellow cards along the way but like you
know like he's been a hell of a
contributor and kind of like proved all
the critics wrong every step along the
way and
a lot of the hatred towards him i think
is based on his religion and his
you know you know being a a strong
pacific honda i genuinely believe that
i'm sorry i go so serious in the podcast
so soon that's good but my even my own
parents i love my parents but they you
know they hate on sonny bill for no
reason whatsoever and i remember my mum
this is horrific but like weird my mom
was like sonny bill he's never smiling
or something like that you know like
kind of i don't know kind of weirdly
having a go islam and she's like look at
this and she showed me a photo on the
paper and it was literally sonny bill at
the
memorial service for christchurch mum's
like he's not smiling of course he's not
smiling like what how is that you know
like and it's just like we just pick any
reason to pick apart especially our top
athletes and especially sonny bill and i
always think like what really is the
reason why you're hating on him because
it can't be because of his record
because he's you know he's been a great
rugby league player great rugby player
and [ __ ] he saved my career so i owe a
lot to sonny bill sorry to go on a rant
but i love that guy that was a good rant
but you thought you did you did speak
about um
the segment where you did go over to
japan and see him how stage was that
because man that looked extremely
awkward oh so awkward no no no not
staged at all rugby press conferences
are really tense yeah and i don't know
why it is maybe you can shed some light
on that i don't know why it is but do
you remember i remember the 2011 rugby
world cup and new zealand's
was so clenched and so tense because we
hadn't won since 87
and i remember there was one press
conference where ali williams and sonny
bill were joking it was ellie williams
and sonny bill were joking around before
like a semi-final or something like that
in the press conference and literally a
journalist told them off like he was
their son or so it was the the weirdest
thing i remember was jim case and
they're like why are you laughing before
semi-finals because because we're
professional athletes and we're human
and we're trying to like you know
lighten up like it's just it's rugby at
the end of the day
and um i'm so glad that those guys did
it and they did it with a smile on their
face and you can enjoy life and be good
at rugby like both those things exist do
you remember that or you asked why they
do that that is exactly why they would
be so serious and why it would be so
intense in there because you've got
journalists like that calling people out
or they can take clips from any segment
like and make you look like you're not
taking it seriously yeah and that
becomes a story right like yeah like
like sonny bill's not ready for the big
game kind of thing and that was so
interesting to me because i would try
when i when the players weren't
available i would try and interview
other journalists and they were all such
interesting people there's a lot of good
rugby journalists in new zealand a lot
of people i really respect but some of
them were just absolute weirdos and they
took it like rugby for them was like
life or death and i understand that it's
a religion in this country but like a
week out for the game you're allowed to
have a few casual jokes especially if it
helps your performance on the field you
know yeah do you know so
that's your expression well that's why
it's so tense it's because the media
will literally clip you out of context
i'd imagine so yeah because i know a lot
of guys when they go to the media um
they don't want to give them anything
just in case it gets taken out of
context yeah that's why i'm hoping like
things like podcasts and stuff are
starting to grow because guys trust the
guy who's on the other end of the
podcast and we can have it loosen up a
little bit yeah it's sad
and that's what i liked about sunny
sunny bell as he did he was when i first
met him especially he was just loose as
a goose you know he'd been over
australia where things are a bit more
fun and um yeah he just like bring
brought a bit of fun to the game i
always yeah found him one of the
funniest players and one of the smartest
players as well yeah but you guys get
along well now uh
yeah good question i always want to tell
my love but i think he got sick of my
[ __ ] like you know i did like five
segments where i would show up out of
the blue yeah and i think eventually it
was like all right mate the jokes played
out but not for me
i'll milk this for what it's worth and
bro those trips are so good because
literally
i think in new zealand might have helped
pay for the flights or whatever it was
but jono and ben the show paid for me to
go to
the second time
they paid for me to go japan so it was
like you know four days in japan we got
sunny on the first day because because
they split the all blacks up and like
half the all blacks went to england
early and while the b team or not the b
team but they're like that the rest of
the players stayed and played japan yeah
and so i had to get sunny bill so i got
up at like three o'clock in the morning
stalked out his hotel until i got him
and then i had like three days in japan
we went to disneyland we went to
shinjuku we tried to get into a um they
have these amazing clubs in japan where
you've been to japan right yeah yeah
they have these clubs where um it's not
like a it's nothing sexual about i don't
know what maybe it is i don't know but
it's like you just go there and just
have a date with a beautiful person so
men go there and they have like a woman
who will just like laugh at your jokes
and stuff but women have that too and we
saw this club and it was like um
pictures of we couldn't really tell what
was going on with their you know we
didn't want to
there's just men who were very
effeminate looking with beautiful makeup
and stuff on the wall and we're like
we've got it whatever this club is i
want to see what's going on here and uh
we walked in and there was a man there
like a tuxedo very well dressed and he
was like get out get out you can speak
english and we can speak japanese he's
like you've got to leave now
and i think it's probably because they
get like either drunken tourists coming
in for a laugh or
um like uh you know gay people and
it's you know maybe homophobic i don't
know what's going on there yeah but um
it was literally men like boyfriends and
a woman after work you go in and you
just hang out with this nice guy who's
nice to you and you pay money and
there's no nothing you don't kiss or
touch or anything like that i found that
so interesting yeah but um kind of cool
as well i don't know what but um yeah
the japan
awesome place you you live live there
for two
six month periods and yeah i never got
to one of those places but i had heard
about them and some i know some of the
guys in my team used to go to them as
well i think it was just a chance for
them to
have a normal chat with someone who they
didn't really know so it is i find it
pretty weird and i know a kiwi chick
makeup artist up in auckland who worked
in one and she was like celebrities
would come in like i had mick jagger uh
britney spears came in like yeah it was
like quite amazing scary because she
said the one she worked at was like run
by like the mob
but yeah but yeah it's like quite
amazing because um she's white with
blonde hair like apparently that was
like a rare obviously because japanese
people were dark here it was like a
rarity yeah so she was like
the whole thing sounds mind-blowing to
me and scary but um yeah pretty special
and then after that
all the clubs strip clubs everything we
couldn't get into the strip club or try
to get [ __ ] embarrassing out loud
we were we had nothing to do in japan we
got sunnyvale but we wanted to go we
didn't listen anywhere um
i don't even know like because like in
shinjuku like it's like if you don't
speak the language you're not allowed in
kind of thing i could be wrong they just
saw my goofy head coming and like get
the hell out we weren't allowed anywhere
we tried to get into the women's club we
tried to get the men's club no club
would let us in and then um the trains
finish at midnight so every club and
bath closed at midnight that's what i
heard but then the batting cage is open
all night
so we went for a bat and that's so cool
it's like an american movie from the i
really enjoyed that and apparently
businessmen do that if you've like
stuffed up your night you live out in
the suburbs you don't want to go home so
you just go do batting cage from like
midnight to like 6 a.m and then go to
work again
it's japanese ingenuity man it's genius
it's so good oh that's 11. yeah what was
your did you enjoyed japan or you like
all business and stuff no we loved it
because it wasn't so much business the
rugby pressure was off the training
hours were very limited and um had heaps
of family time heaps of chance to go and
explore japan and
see what it was and the family all loved
it so they miss a little bit but um you
do get annoyed with some parts of the
japanese culture but here we go let's
let's let's kick that off is this going
to take a weird racist twist what's
going on what's annoying about this it's
things like um just things that we're
used to here in terms of small things
like um cash everything's cash
everything's paper written so you can't
everything just seems to take forever so
like if you need to get something you've
got to go through about 10 different
people yeah the bureaucracy massive list
of things and then you've got to have
all your paperwork sorted which when
you're used to it here you just got your
sort of id and yeah card and you hand it
over and everything gets done where
that's the thing we take for granted new
zealand how lacks everything is even
when you go to the states as well it's
like they have so many you know you go
to sports game you go through a metal
detector yeah i think just a bigger
population means you've got to be
stricter but yeah japanese bureaucracy
the irony of that is japan's like famous
for the opposite right they're famous
for vending machines and bullet trains
yeah yeah so that's really interesting
that i've never lived there that is a
taurus it's very easy but as a local
what what sort of stuff we're trying to
get that required payments the driver's
license it's like a license like even
you've got to register your car it's all
every car on the road has to have his
own car park and it has to have proof by
the police and things like that even
trying to get internet or tv you've got
to go through so many paper trails do
you know what's so interesting though is
like um you know i just think of the
cliche thing about japan you always talk
about the vinnie machines but um
i don't know if there actually is you
know if you always joke about there
being a huge penny vinnie machine or
something like that i don't i don't know
if that's maybe it is maybe it is i mean
i mean yeah who knows but um the uh the
thing that interests me is that i i
distinctly remember i'm pretty sure
cigarettes and beer from vending
machines yeah and i was so interested in
is that is that true is that yeah yeah
you can get beer i'm not sure about
cigarettes anymore but maybe okay so
my point being is that like everywhere
in the world you go seems to have except
for maybe america it seems to have like
a
more mature response to drinking than
new zealand it's like in new zealand
literally i remember the wellington
sevens they like closed it down because
new zealand like couldn't just like you
know like just slow it down a little bit
you know and it's like so interesting
and in japan they're literally selling
alcohol out of vending machines like if
we did that in new zealand people would
die you know like it's like it's every
country in the world and you go to like
um italy and stuff and kids are just
drinking wine in the street and you're
like that kid's not 18 or whatever yeah
but they seem to be
handling it better than we are it's like
we're i don't know what's wrong with our
say we're a bit we're a bit off the off
the rocker a little bit i think yeah and
you don't drink either do you so yeah
that's an interesting one to chat about
yeah so what am i doing at the batting
cage at 2 a.m just having a good you can
have a good time without alcohol guys
yeah or drugs yeah sorry what you're
going to ask something yeah so like
the reasoning for you to not drink and i
mean you've already got the confidence
of someone who's pretty much hammered
already
what's the reasoning behind you not
drinking i guess oh it's a bit of a it's
a bit of a long story but um alcohol
issues run in my family so i like saw at
quite a young age not my parents but um
you know grandparents and stuff battle
with addiction and how that can change
people and how that can affect people
yeah and also um
i
so my mom basically just like scared me
out of it when i was like at high school
and stuff like that so i didn't drink
and then
through that time when you don't drink
you see all the negative repercussions
and so that kind of reinforces your
stereotype like i saw kids
do crazy stuff at high school i saw
um things that you you know i used to
come back from basketball practice at
like 9 00 p.m
um to the uni hostel and there'd just be
a whole bunch of
um people in their rooms crying because
like you know their boyfriend had
cheated on them or um someone had
punched them in town it was just kind of
like i saw like the cat the art the bad
aftermath you see when you're sober and
um that really kind of like um shook me
a little bit yeah it was just kind of it
was just kind of eye-opening and so from
there comedy is like riddled with like
alcohol and drug problems obviously
almost every famous comedian um besides
now getting um being like a weird creep
yeah um but also so many famous
comedians have so struggled with drugs
and alcohol it's um yeah it's a big it's
a big problem so it just yeah it became
a no-brainer have you ever had pressure
to feel like you need to take it
massively massively yeah bro all the way
through uni and stuff like that and i
used to just it was easy i just used to
have a beer
one beer the whole night not even
finish like the neck of it just
occasionally take a sip and just if you
had a beer in your hand it like solved
the problem occasionally i'd like to
have a can of baked beans not even
notice as long as you the only time
you'll comment on it is if your hands
are empty then people are like what's
going on here but if you've just got
something in your hand people just won't
question you it could be just glass of
water it's sweet yeah it can invade
being surely not and also if your
friends are gonna like be [ __ ] about
it um if a friend's gonna be [ __ ]
about it they're probably not that good
friends you know people do worry if
you're not drinking and they are
drinking
they get um they think you're judging
them which you're not doing oh okay if
they're like vomiting out in the bushes
then you are judging them a little bit
but like you know generally you're not
judging them and like you you normally
lose those people who are [ __ ] when
they're when they're drunk are normally
not great people when they're sober
anyway so you kind of normally drift
away from those people anyway you know
yeah so a lot of people drink to get a
bit of self-confidence i guess and to be
able to feel a little bit more
comfortable but
you've got this gift to be extremely
confident and comfortable in any
situation yeah yeah yeah it's delusional
self-confidence really um
i think a few things helped one was just
realizing quite early on that everyone
struggles with that like everyone feels
awkward you think the biggest toughest
captain of the first 15 yeah he's got
anxiety issues that's why he you know
everyone is like knocking them back to
try and chill out a little bit or get
more confidence on the dance floor and
once you realize that you're like [ __ ]
it's all just a weird bravado thing
anyway and you can just kind of fake it
till you make it and i'm not always
super confident or anything like that
but one thing that really helped was
stand up because like once you've
realized your worst fear which is
talking to 100 people in a bar getting
no laughs getting like a slow clap like
get off the stage once you've
experienced that you're like [ __ ] it's
not that bad i can handle that i can
bomb any night of the week like it's
like you realize like yeah it's
it's fine and and then i just kind of
like was like you may as well just try
and enjoy yourself a little bit i still
get really self-conscious what's funny
is that when people go um
oh man you must be so
drunk or stoned when you do what you do
yeah and i could be like yeah man i was
wasted no i didn't smoke weed either i
didn't do anything you know it's so
embarrassing to be like you think that
i'm drunk but really that's just that's
just me man yeah and you mentioned uh
your stand-up comedy how did you get to
the step where you get to that point you
see that's like the the loss of loss
being up
on this on the stage and not getting any
laughs yeah how do you even get to that
stage obviously that's an incredible it
would be an incredible fear for anyone
to attempt to do that yeah when you
start it's just hard and you learn
what not to do quite early on it's stamp
comedy's so good because it's like trial
and error i was like
it's so interesting just looking at
professional athletes it must be such an
interesting job being a rugby player
because
you can't make mistakes really you know
like i don't know
you look at like guys you're like 21
years old and you're playing super rugby
or whatever
you must think like man if i throw a few
bad passes here i'm my life so you know
do you
there's quite amazing pressure on this
am i right am i wrong i sort of feel
like that you've got another 14 guys
around you when you're out there so if
you do make a couple of mistakes then
not you know the the team can sort of
look after you where i look as a look at
a comedian and you're up there by
yourself you've got no one else to um
help you or nah nah the stakes are so
low though like if you bomb like because
like when i was bombing and stuff like
that hard like you're starting out you
you're not getting paid so you don't
really care like yeah you're not letting
anyone down really and um i at the time
i bombed real bad i was opening for
raybon khan so i leave him down but he's
only paid me 35 bucks or stuff something
so how well i mean i earned my 35 bucks
just for doing my time but um yeah it's
it's just uh the stakes are so low and
comedy is about mistakes like literally
my ratio to good jokes and bad jokes is
probably about five bad ones to one good
one maybe even higher than that yeah and
that's just like you look comedy is all
about learning from your mistakes
there's really no rules there's no
academy you can't practice in front of
your mirror you've just got to go up
there and just see if it works or not
and um so that makes it uh like really
comforting and you just go like kind of
new joke old new jerk old joke and then
when you're doing a big show you have a
lot of old jokes that you can fall back
on if the new jokes aren't working so
there is a big safety net there yeah um
yeah okay so so in rugby
sorry to go back to rugby i do have some
really good rugby stories by the way i
should tease that yeah do you want it do
you want to hear my rugby story
it's vaguely rugby laters yeah you're
not keen no i'm keen yes
um jeff wilson is a lovely guy yeah i've
met him multiple times he is the best
guy but he's also very competitive and i
think he won't mind me telling the story
anyway um it doesn't make him look that
bad but um
i play basketball grew up playing
basketball and uh started a team with my
brother a few years ago just playing um
fairly socially well you say social
there's no
damn men in their 30s playing sport man
they take it too seriously you ever play
like just like corporate touch or
something and people go so hard and like
it's life or death if you're an
accountant like your last chance is to
score a score try playing social touch
but it was so it was auckland north
shore which is like the best competition
in auckland b grade
so i thought it was pretty casual level
um but my team would have players
getting thrown out of the game every it
was people got too serious about it and
the ref was always like a 14 year old
kid it was embarrassing we're fully
grown men and oh god it's so sad the way
some people still holding on to those
nba dreams eh you're lucky you got to
experience that man you're lucky you got
to go like as high as you could go right
so you can't you're not going to be like
what if kind of thing yeah because so
many kiwi males like finish at high
school and go like oh that could have
been me out there yeah and um so yeah so
anyway um so we're there living our nba
wannabe ambitions and we come up against
um
former all black legend one of the
greatest new zealand sports people ever
jeff wilson and one of my personal
heroes that was my childhood right there
like goldie he's such a legend played
cricket as well
and the rumor is that he was also
awesome at basketball like you know the
rumor was that he scored a hundred point
game or so i can't remember but the
story at high school he was the man
right at three sports basketball cricket
and rugby and always a joke was that
like
like rugby was l he's the best at it but
it was his least favorite apparently i
wanted to spell the rumor now that he's
not
that good at basketball
like can i know that's like people talk
about him like he could have been like
he's okay he's pretty good hey and if
he'd if he'd quit his other two sports
that he was amazing at he probably could
have been like awesome at basketball
because he's an athlete he could do
anything yeah but he's sure obviously
rugby builds so he's quite stocky he's
not really a basketball his build and
he's okay but you can tell that he's
someone who's stopped barcelona quite
young young and stuff like that but
still very competitive
and the first game was kind of niggly
right like my brother plays point guard
my brother um lovely guy but he uh he
can get too serious sometimes and him
and jeff wilson were kind of flopping
for fouls and pushing each other over it
was getting a little bit titchy
and his team and i think they'll be okay
with me saying this were the biggest
a-holes i've ever played against jeff
wilson the guy pushing my brother over
was the nice guy the rest of them were
dirty old tall black new zealand player
okay the new zealand rugby team for
people don't know is called the tall
blacks i'm not calling them tall black
men none of them were very tall but none
of them were black they were white guys
but they played for new zealand back in
the day and they're elbowing me they're
just so dirty grabbing me pulling me
like it was just the whole thing was
just an or they're the worst team to
play against and the only saving grace
was you get to meet jeff wilson
so the second time we play him i'm like
that's jeff wilson these guys are
a-holes let's have a bit of banter mate
and um he's quite physical so i would
just like kind of riff with him a little
bit what i thought was riffing and um
and i'd be like it's not the bleeder's
low cut mate i'll chill out we're not
playing rugby anymore mate this is like
96 all over again i don't even know what
96 was just throwing a random year out
there stuff like that and but for
whatever reason it's a sporting like
focus he just did not take any of it
lightly eh and i just remember saying
chill out jeff it's not the blitz low
mate and he was just like he's looked at
me stone cold in the face and just goes
i never thought you were funny
so cold so me like jeff chill out man
it's b grade north shore wednesday night
basketball
so it's it's quite tense then i felt bad
i almost wanted to apologize because i
kind of realized afterwards that here's
some bad memories from the blitz logan
like um didn't uh uh
george george grigon hit the ball out of
his hand and stuff like that and i
wasn't referencing was that 96. no maybe
not no i don't know but anyway whatever
it was i was not referencing that i was
just trying to i don't know that much
about rugby i was trying to throw out a
rugby reference right
so then this is weird it was the game
was already tense because it was so
rough
um but it made it tenser my banter this
is the comedy it goes bad my banter went
backfired right and then i felt like i
was being an [ __ ] to jeff and he was
being an [ __ ] to me and it just
wasn't very nice
this is where it gets weird the game is
really close they're we're about 20
years younger than them but they're just
battling for everything they yell for a
foul every time they're so old they kind
of intimidate the referees get some
cheap free throws and stuff like that
yeah somehow we're still battling with
these guys
game tied it sounds like i'm making this
up i swear there's video evidence of
this there's game tied
there's four seconds left we have the
ball we're inbounding the ball from the
side attacking our hoop so it's in our
half right the game is the score is tied
we drew up a play we call a timeout drop
play this is intense that's always a
mistake right drawing up a play with a
if you've got a coach and you're a
trained team that makes sense you've got
to play that you're used to running not
when you're just standing around and
everyone goes oh yeah i'll screen there
and everyone just has a hoon right so
the players that um i'm gonna screen for
our best player who's gonna run off and
shoot a three to win the game and if
that fails if that gets denied then
we're gonna hit me rolling to the hoop
and i'm gonna catch it and do a layup
right
what happens is i go to set a screen and
this tall black guy again he's a white
guy who's the team's called the tour
blacks
he just bullies me i should have known
this was going to happen he just pushes
me off the spot and then um he just
grabs me like just beer hugs me right
yeah they their guy gets our best
shooter gets defended off my screen or
whatever hell i'm doing i'm not really
doing anything at this point because of
the guy i've been pushed off my mark he
runs out he's guarded because i got
pushed off my mark and then he just the
guy just grabs me like literally just
hugs me so i can't run and get the ball
my brother you've got five seconds in
bound
lobs the ball to where i should be but i
can't move because he's literally
holding me with his arm like rugby it
shouldn't be allowed right
the ball bounces into play another one
of their players grabs the ball
throws it american football style the
length of the floor so this is
three-quarters court throw goes the
length of the court
in swish they win the game
jeff wilson is just like yes and i'm so
excited i'm just like yes and i go and
hug jeff wilson i'm like goldie we did
it bro i'm not on the team my brother's
pissed off at me he's like what they're
on your team stop doing that don't be a
dick
and uh it was that was the greatest
moment in my sporting career
it sounds unbelievable there's video
footage of that shot going in i've never
seen a shot like my basketball career go
three quarter core even without pressure
let alone to win the game amazing
basketball and it's absolutely good
yeah
so bad so bad hey that is good is that
is that an insult that people give to
you all the time is that i've never
found you funny or you're not funny is
that like everyone's go-to yeah yeah
yeah and it's hard one to come back from
as well because she's gonna be like oh
uh comedy is uh subjective and everyone
has an opinion but um i understand it as
well because um some people i mean the
reason jeff wilson i mean jeff olson
might not have been funny that's totally
fine it's his opinion but um uh he said
it because i was bantering with him and
he was like all right well you're gonna
give it to me i'm gonna give it to you
kind of thing so i kind of was asking
for a little bit there talk [ __ ] get hit
you know but um people just will come up
to the when people are mean about it at
least so now like new zealand today is
so well received a lot of stuff i did on
jono and ben people didn't like but new
zealand today is quite light yeah i'm so
lucky thank god i've done one good thing
in my life
um besides hug jefforsson after i lost
the game of basketball so i um
uh yeah so so if he'll say there's no
real comeback you just could be like uh
comedy is subjective and everyone has an
opinion and um and yeah it's one of
those things where um i understand it
because there's comedians i hate and
can't understand why people like them
yeah and you realize it's like music
even more extreme like people hear a
certain type of music and they just
don't understand you know country music
or whatever it's like everyone has
people they like and they don't like and
some of the some of the most comedian
popular comedians in the world are
people i just don't understand why
people like them at all yeah it's really
interesting that is interesting and you
talk and i mean something that's growing
a lot in rugby at the moment is
like social media abuse and like people
sliding into the dms just abusing
players so i'd imagine a comedian gets
at times 10 so what how have you dealt
with that in year i just started
ignoring it and um i think that's the
only way to do it um yeah it's so tough
on rug again it's like that thing of
like for how serious journalists take it
and how they think it's life or death a
lot of the fans are like that too
unfortunately because we put so much
investment in them like we are living
vicariously through athletes right yeah
like when um bowdoin barrett kicks it
it's me going how did you miss it and
he's gonna look back and go it's hard
man it's not easy i'm trying my best
and uh yeah
it's um i i just took the because when i
started in comedy i used to literally
this is so sad i would actually go on
twitter type my name in and see what
people are writing yeah and you know
like there's a reason why they haven't
added me it's because they want to go
guy williams is not funny get him off
the show because you know yeah and so
it's like why was i subjecting myself to
that abuse and i quickly realized it was
like if you just don't read it to an
extent every time i go on because most
social media is largely
uh pretty no it's
i'd say actually largely it's pretty
good but like
if you plumb into the depths you will
find some stuff just like um
right now with all the disinformation
around you know basic you know science
around vaccines and stuff like that yeah
i sort of post doing music asking for
season because
you know it's been locked down and stuff
like that people
people like uh don't have much to do so
in lockdown i was like um hey uh i need
ideas for season three of new zealand
today and most people are like great and
having good ideas yeah and a few people
got in there it's because like um the
communist government is here to um shut
down uh
control our people and put us into camps
i don't know what the hell is going on
there but like pete you know like you're
just like who are you and i almost feel
sorry for those people now and like yeah
where they're going like what sort of
life are you living if you like if you
see the all blacks lose a rugby game or
see your favorite the hurricanes lose
rugby game and log on there and decide
you're going to abuse your you're the
pill you're a fan of you know like it's
kind of like it almost just reflects so
badly on them i end up feeling i end up
feeling angry about them and then sorry
for them you know yeah and it's such a
big thing now and what's worse is that
women get it so much worse and uh you
know people of color if you're brown
you're going to get so much worse as
well it's like um
it's it's it's it's sad to see and um
yeah i feel i really feel for athletes
because it's yeah it's ruined some
people's careers i reckon yeah it
definitely has and you talked about um
some of those people who have some crazy
beliefs and now i guess the cool thing
about your show new zealand today is you
get to go meet these people talk to them
and yeah yeah get to know them a little
bit yeah and i and i must say i'm like
walking a fine line there because i
think this
the the good thing about new zealand
today i think should be
that like
you realize that most people
out there are good people there's some
people who are just like wrong yeah and
there's some people who
you know whether they be on drugs or
alcohol or off the drugs they should be
on yeah i have got like a screw loose
but most people even people i've met
flat earthers or people who i'm like
what is wrong with you yeah you talk to
them for a few hours and you're like
actually you're all right
you know you've just like you know
you've just gone down a few too many
youtube rabbit holes
and ended up in a weird place where they
think um they think bro they think the
world the world is flat it's surrounded
by an antarctic ice wall that's guarded
by nasa that's what they think because
because you know when the people go the
world is flat they go um how come you
can't just sail a boat off the end of it
and they're like because there's there's
guards there guarding and you're like oh
man this is so and it's the same it's
the same with it doesn't take long till
you start getting there on
matters of science and stuff like that
and you realize that kind of the saddest
thing when i talk to the flat earther
and this is the person who believes
everything like she
her thera you know she'll believe she'll
see a school shooting in the us and
believe it was perpetrated by the
government to crack down on guns like
it's just like absolutely outrageous as
things they think and um
uh
don't get me wrong there are legitimate
conspiracies out there there are things
out there we need more information as to
um how things like how climate change
has been covered up by oil companies
there's definitely things out there that
need to be investigated yeah i mean
people still people start on their
rabbit hole down the jfk
is weird probably not time to talk about
it right now
but um
she said a thing that was like so heart
breaking to me and i was like i don't
believe you like why would i believe you
like when all the scientists are saying
that earth is a globe and she was like
almost crying and she was like why won't
you believe me i just want to be
believed and i was like oh that just
broke my heart that yeah all she wanted
to do was
if you are in a conspiracy theory group
or whatever you just you feel smart
you're all of a sudden like a leader
you're like no all the world's leading
scientists and universities are idiots i
know what's best
and um do you know what i think it's
interesting to relate that to rugby it's
really interesting how every dude in new
zealand and probably woman as well
think they know what the all blacks
coach should be doing or what the
hurricanes coach should be what the
coach should be doing
um rather than like people who are
experts have spent their life perfecting
the game and somehow me sitting on the
couch knows what they should be doing
you know yeah yeah you get it so much
yeah yeah and unfortunately rugby
players aren't held in the same uh
esteem as a
mit scientist
but still you are like in your chosen
field um that's what you guys are and
people still think oh they obviously
should have spread it earlier you know
it's like it's not that easy do you find
that is that quite weird like you know
you knowing the game now do you get
annoyed by like the average punters on
social media and stuff oh man you just
sort of find it more funny than anything
everyone does have an opinion everyone's
passionate about the game so that that's
more than anything else but um everyone
has an opinion on who should be selected
and a lot of those things uh guys who
have the video highlight so i mean i was
always one of those guys who they never
really wanted out there because i i
wasn't big fast or strong so i never had
the video packages yeah or i didn't look
like one of those players who was
contributing to the side but my
strengths were all the things that you
don't really see on tv you know like the
communication the decision making and
that sort of stuff so yeah as a plow i
always felt like i
was copying it more than others because
i didn't have that that the fans would
want to see the guys the bigger stronger
faster guys
who you'd see breaking the tackle so i
think that's definitely part of it as
well but you become like a fan favorite
because people see you and they see
someone who
almost looks like them it's funny steph
curry is the most popular basketball
player partly because he looks like a
normal person he's not yeah he's like um
my height he's like six foot four or
something like that yeah and he's the
greatest shooter of all time but
compared to the other freaks on the
court he looks like a normal human being
he looks short um yeah it's kind of
interesting i mean that's why you became
a fan favorite same with marty banks as
well you know like you don't look like
people who necessarily would
traditionally be out there
so i think that's why people identify
with you so much you know um but can i
ask you about strategy then because i um
you'd probably have definitely seen this
game um assuming you're in new zealand
last year's
itm cup final tasman marco versus
auckland do you see that game oh yes so
i went there tickets were free it was
crazy it was so good and supporting the
marco obviously and
uh it just blew my obviously great win
for the marco fins up to the boys
unbelievable were you there actually at
the game i was at the walker two
actually oh awesome the non-23 the guys
who didn't travel
we'd had a bit of a day of it and was
that because they covered why the 23
knot trailer that's gutting they
couldn't be there for the final no they
they're just funds really oh wow oh
that's a shame um i won't just hire a
rental van and just drive up there for
the night man it was disgusting yeah
tickets were free too yeah
i didn't have to pay admission charge so
anyway so that game just blew my mind
because i think auckland was unbeaten to
that point or pretty close were they
they were favourites they were hot for
they were not just favorites so weren't
they hot favorites okay i'm just
tweeting my ass now um but my point
being is that i watched that game and
auckland had a crazy strategy which was
constantly kicking high balls for
territory i'm guessing or to reclaim it
they kicked all game had no position as
a result or or gave up a lot of position
and seemed to lose the game and at half
time i was like oh man
tasman's going well but once auckland
starts holding on to the ball and i know
nothing about rugby like i'm so far from
an expert besides a casual fan
i couldn't figure out why auckland at
halftime didn't change their um strategy
to go through the hands and stop kicking
away position yeah and i was like you as
a rugby fan did you understand what
auckland were doing are you at the
walker two going what are they doing now
it's a real common part of rugby now
like you're seeing more and more of it
even the world cup was won by the team
who kicked it the most like teams are
just getting so good on defense that
when you kick it you can put teams under
pressure with your d and um
get penalties and get turnovers from
there and then be able to kick for the
corner once you've got that penalty and
then really attack sort of save your
energy as well by not playing too much
in your half so
there's i mean it's just the way the
game's gone and i you hear it all the
time what like my grandma's my nana's
the worst she she used to hate when i'd
kicked the ball she why are you always
tapping the ball like that's part of the
plan yeah yeah yeah no no i don't mean
that but i mean like specifically in
that final did you not think at half
time man auckland the kicking game is
backfiring because tasman had a few line
breakers or something like that or like
they were tasman were turning the
uh position what are the three pieces of
rugby position position points is that
what it is oh we'll go with that i like
that nelson have you ever heard that the
three piece of rugby griggy nah nah not
greggy um uh the guy who i can't
remember the guy's name he was not a
teacher at the school and he was just a
coach to coach like the under 14 team or
whatever um i love nelson college it's a
great school but this teacher this no
sorry not teacher this coach he told us
position position points the three p's
of rugby and then he told us that
winning gives him a boner and he got
fired
and the poor bastard because like
looking back on it now
like he was doing an adult joke that was
not good for kids
but like but yeah you can see why he got
fought you know like like the head of
nelson college rugby or whatever was
like his son was on the team or whatever
so he got like the guy was get you to
the march he was like stop talking about
your boner you're weirdo around kids but
like it was like weird he didn't know um
apparently got reinstated a few years
later or something like that but um yeah
he taught me winning some boner and
position position points and that's
about when i quit rugby to be honest as
they're about when i quit rugby to be
honest so how was your rugby career by
the way not great i played with simon
mannering i played a game with simon
manning we used to play against um
mulberry boys every year and we were
locked together oh yeah he's just down
the road at my pool
wait so marpus you've got michael
coleman yeah simon mannering yeah and my
brother tom wow
that's amazing the legion he doesn't
remember i think we caught him on the
radio once again remember when you play
with me i mean it was literally one game
yeah so mannering i think he left nelson
college quite early to go he was in the
warriors development he was big time
yeah but um i don't know why there's one
game because especially because it was a
joke game where we were way overpowered
for them we thrashed them but um
uh yeah i a few a few of those players i
used to play bastard with tim bateman
and um michael cohen and the red team
yeah a few a few players who went on to
be um professionals and my basketball
crew got dunked on by tom abercrombie uh
many times many times he was what i
should have been like he was me but with
athleticism as well he was he was
impressive um but uh
yeah so i played rugby like i was big
for my age yeah so i caught and nelson
weirdly we didn't do i think in auckland
they do it by weight but um i mean it's
probably a racial thing really because
um people got sick of bigger
developing pacific island boys beating
up their white kids so they like they
like racistly changed it whereas in
nelson we were all whites or like white
power
i'm joking by the way i'm joking um uh
so we uh we did it by age so as a result
i was big for my age and oh russell
pecker he actually got dispensated
upgrades because he was so powerful even
at a young age his brother was on my
team and marist we were bad but we got
um russell pekka league player we'll see
nelson uh yeah for a few years he played
he played for my team for a couple years
but he was he just retired last this he
was literally dispensated up for two
years my dad coached him um he went to
jail he's like dead bad coaching man bad
i don't know why russell went to jail
but he's turned around i think he's
doing well now i think but um shout out
to russell if you're out there let's
catch up sometime reminisce about under
13 marist losing games by 60 points but
um yeah so i played i played uh to an
average level i made the rip teams
because it was big and my dad um helped
coach yeah i think that's only why and
um i was fine but then i switched to
basketball literally because
in rugby
my only job really was kind of line out
specialist and
run it straight hit the deck place it
back kind of thing yeah and i was fine
at that but like you know like um
uh basketball i was shooting i was
scoring it was just so much you know you
get the ball more it was just so much
more enjoyable um so that's kind of why
it was a no-brainer and you were a bit
of a wizard at basketball too
you're pretty damn good people it's
funny because um the what's to say and
the older i get the better i was
people because i'm a comedian people
remember it for me because they like it
as a story and like articles they're
like he was an awesome basketball player
i wasn't really like i was okay i played
for my high school which was good you
know nelson college we were good um and
then um lots of years ago wasn't it many
years many years and then i tried to
make it to the next level i played for
the saints for two years i was like a
development player and got on the court
a couple of times went on a couple of
road trips and just wasn't up to it as i
said like
the standard was so high even the best
players from my school
never really of you know the same school
as you uh
the best players never even really made
it like
jeremiah truman made the tall blacks i
think and um
hugh quinlivan maybe played a bit of mbl
but like even the players that i looked
up to who were like amazing it's like
the standard to be a pro and that's why
you should be so stoked man like it's so
high you know the average punter doesn't
realize that i'm lucky that i got to try
yeah and i realized that the level above
like i had i'm tall i'm big i can shoot
uh i was fit but i just the next level
is athleticism and speed yeah and when
you don't have that you've got to be
really onto it and um yeah i just wasn't
quite up to it but i'm glad i gave it my
best you know so why is new zealand
basketball so far off like
mba level well yeah
is it it's like getting there well we're
a tiny country america has 400 million
people we have three
and the nba is like the best in the
world like it's not just the best
americans it's the best uh from europe
as well but um uh it's more comparing us
to australia and again they're five
times bigger than us it's more it's more
why is new zealand rugby so good it's
more interesting than why is basketball
so bad basketball's about where it
should be we consider we've got a player
in the nba we've had multiple people
like have 10 day contracts in the nba um
new zealand uh the gm of the um brooklyn
nets is a kiwi shawn marks yeah yeah
yeah yeah blows your mind yeah i um
cause some kiwis were the videographers
you know new zealanders man we're so as
i said you know how america like japan
is so strict and like security so tight
the kiwi videographers were like come to
the brooklyn
facility man and i go in there and it's
like the most beautiful basketball
training facility you've ever seen
you've got a hair salon in their
training facility and stuff
their basketball courts overlook the new
york skyline from brooklyn yeah and sean
marx is just there um
riding the unicycle or the unicycle he's
running a unicycle around the court like
a clown he's juggling riding the
exorcical and i like mixed your marks
and it was like growing up i idolized
him and like when he played for the tall
blacks um i've explained what the two
blacks are now so i don't need any more
explanation uh i was like i just like
gushed over me i was just like um i say
when i meet um uh whenever i meet
stephen adams i'm like the whole of new
zealand's proud
and he's like just can you
chill out man just be cool for a second
i'm so proud of you man
it's just it's a weird thing in new
zealand we're like revenant it's like
whenever i've met richie mccoy i'm like
sir richard
nice to meet you sir sir i'm just like
so yeah i don't know why i'm like that
but um you know when you got one chance
to meet someone it's better than like
being nonchalant and like going like oh
yeah good to meet you whatever i like
i'm glad that i told sean marx i thought
he was awesome and i'm glad i told
stephen adams cnn's just after the third
time he's like you've just got to chill
a little bit man and pull your [ __ ]
together but new zealand basketball's
actually actually all right i thought i
thought my year was going to be the year
and they've done pretty well like um tom
abercrombie corey webster with the two
that they just kicked mars every year
high school nationals yeah they um they
won multiple i mean with americans and
australians on their team too but the
breakers have won dominated the
australian league like they won like
four championships so like you're
considering like look at the warriors
like how hard it is to win in australia
yeah yeah
sorry trigger word i like set off
yeah sorry to bring them up man but um
it's so hard to be a competitive sports
team um in australia i think usually in
basketball overall with no funding is
like doing all right and it's like
constantly like on the on the on the
upper there's a lot of good players i
take back my comment completely you've
sold it well
new zealand basketball is strong
honestly you look at the funding they
get like a hundred grand a year or
something for like the whole budget and
i mean they've got like it's one of the
most played sports by young people it's
like it's growing man mainly because
parents just like don't want their kids
to get concussed and um
what was the other one uh uh it's
indoors like you know like people like
rugby so someone had appealing to in a
cold morning in the south island as
opposed to going to a heated gym on like
a wednesday night it's like so much
nicer um
one of my favorite instagram posts was
you
was you uh you took a photo of um
the will smith film concussion or
whatever
and your caption was like not the best
game movie to watch before a big game
did you um can i
yeah did you literally see it before a
game literally saw it before a game and
the guy i watched it with james
broadhurst had to retire due to
concussion good on him for doing that
though yeah well he had to do he had no
other option oh wow he was pretty he was
pretty [ __ ] but i mean
how many um how many concussions have
you had or like too many accounts it was
two in the same game which back to back
and just really rocked him so wow how
old is he
he just he just that made his debut for
the all blacks maybe um
two weeks earlier got released came back
to play for taranaki and it was that
game so he would have been about
let me guess around 26 27.
that's that's that's yeah that is that
is tragic but i think like i mean he can
probably see this as well like it's
probably saved his life right yeah
huge and it's so it's so big um
uh yeah it's such a big like it's the
the knock-on effects of too many
concussions my brother only played rugby
till he was like 12 or 13 and he i
coached him he was a bloody good player
you coached him genuinely he was our
team wow
yeah oh i didn't even tell me that
that's hilarious okay he probably
doesn't remember he was a good tackler
yeah
good uh good uh good uh good runner and
he um
uh yeah but he had a lot of concussions
like early on and i remember when you're
a kid he would be like seven years old
he'd knock himself out tackling he'd go
off to the side like you know dry vomit
and then go back out there yeah and i
was like we just had no idea that the
damage was like did you have many
concussions in your career was it a few
but um yeah i was always pretty tried to
be pretty sensible around i'd never go
back on if i felt like i wasn't yeah um
right so yeah it's question so your
friend were you watching that movie
before he had to retire or after or uh
well yeah
maybe that was the movie that pushed it
no but seriously um i this
i i heard a story about uh i mean this
might be totally inappropriate i don't
know i should really google my facts
before i just spout them on a podcast
but no it's the craziest and one of the
sad stories is um
a
retired american football player who
shot himself uh he took his own life
tragically through his own chest because
he wanted his brain to be studied for
cte study like that was he he in his
mind had decided that this had affected
him so badly yeah that um and it like
leads to so like literally cuts ears off
your life and stuff like that it's such
a serious thing and it's interesting in
new zealand i feel like we haven't
talked about it quite enough late in
america it was a huge scandal in the nfl
such a big business they've just kind of
rolled you know made a few rules and
rolled on yeah but like it's gonna
become a bigger and bigger thing and i
mean every couple of years someone racks
up the talk that callers or whatever by
saying you know should we have you know
touch rugby up into a certain age but
like when you look at the facts it
probably makes sense especially because
kids rugby what are they learning
tackling the [ __ ] out of each other when
they're seven years i think i can't
remember when i started tackling but i
think it was like eight years old or
something it's like the game is just a
mess there it's just a ball and you're
all just pushing and shut you know no
one knows how to play there's no spread
out or like there's no back line yeah so
like you're playing scrag there anyway
it probably makes it more sense to have
like more of a touch game and actually
learn the fundamentals of passing both
ways and i think they've gone that
ripper tag up a little bit higher now
which makes more sense you're still
trying to rip around the hip so it's a
little bit more like a tackle so and i
understand why people are angry and it's
kind of crazy because like the world
really is going the other way with mma
where people just like embrace it get
the money and go but like
um yeah it's it's one of those things
that just fascinates me it's so
interesting
what questions do you hate as a rugby
player like what questions do you hate
getting
because like rugby players are famous
for bad answers but we ask dumb
questions
you know like
all those ones where you pretty much
have to cliche it like yeah yeah like
you can't there's no other way to go
about it and if you don't do that it'll
be bulletin board material for the other
team especially if a team
that you play a pretty [ __ ] and they say
oh what do you think of their
performance
they were a lot tougher than the
scoreboard suggested yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh yeah they were [ __ ] useless yeah
if you did one day though you've gone to
youtube and be a legend forever though
it would be worth it it'd be worth it so
yeah the question you always get is how
did you get to comedy and there's a very
easy answer to that and the answer is
i'm a privileged white male who grew up
quite well off and i looked at all the
jobs in the world and i wanted my dream
to be a professional athlete and i
wasn't good enough and i want to be a
professional movie star or a musician
but i can't sing and i i'm not
good-looking at all so the next thing
you fall down to is comedy man it's like
the it's like the ugly person's way into
the entertainment industry
and uh it's the dream job like i was
like why
i think i mean a lot of people are
terrified of the idea of like doing
comedy in front of an audience so you
got to get that confidence up but like
even just like any sort of comedy for a
living even if you made edited or like
wrote jokes behind the scenes it's quite
a great job to have it's like being an
ice cream tester or a professional
surfer and um yeah so i just like got
into it as a hobby and um have just
loved it and been so lucky ever since
like they literally my life has been
so easy i've no one's had more privilege
than me like i literally came out of
high school went to uni started doing
comedy and got a go i got a job i had a
few weird jobs in between but like i
literally a month out of graduating
after spending two extra years at
university doing a three-year degree
i um got a job as a professional
comedian basically not paying much but
still i just like absolutely
and the jammiest buggy you've ever seen
because i'm not even particularly
talented or anything like that just um
yeah the confidence of a mediocre white
man
this guy right here did you know you're
funny though nah never funny no not
really i just knew i liked comedy um i
knew i think everyone two things i think
whenever you see because people see me
and go oh i'm funnier than him do comedy
then do like get into it like it's like
there's
so many other things like even in rugby
you need to be discovered like you need
to go to a school and you need to like
you need a chance you need to get seen
by the right people there's
opportunities even like raw talent
probably will get you discovered but
it's not nothing's a meritocracy but
comedy is like the bar is so low you
let's just go to a bar turn up and start
doing jokes on stage and see how you go
yeah like there's so few um rules to it
and i think everyone there's never been
an oversupply of comedy like if you want
to get into the industry try and get
into it and it's like um in new zealand
there's been almost more jobs than i
mean i sound like an arrogant [ __ ]
now for me anyway there's been more jobs
than um i've been able to to hold on to
but i mean that's not been the case i've
been luckier than most yeah but um yeah
it's just uh you literally just uh sign
up for a open mic at any comedy club i
weirdly um i thought i was getting asked
out on a date
a girl who was my friend um asked me
to go to a comedy show with her and i
thought she was asking me on a date so i
was like great kind of you know i didn't
try too hard i'm in new zealand i don't
want to look like i care about anything
in the world but um you know like i you
know i you know had a shower and dressed
myself up a little bit
and got there and there was like five
other people there turns out we were
like rent a crowd for her brother's
stand-up gig oh that's true but that
night so i was a little bit crystal
my my plan was to bring flowers and
thank god i did the kiwi bloke thing of
like nah don't get flowers thank god i
didn't because that would have been
awkward as hell but i got to the gig and
literally um
had the best night of my life like it
was terrible yeah worst the comedians i
don't want to name the comedians now but
like none of the comedians were like
people who were successful then or
successful now none of them are like
reputable names or anything like that
but they just
the magic just happened which happens in
comedy everyone just caught fire and one
guy did a bit that was called giving
birth to the wall
and
just when you're laughing and you just
you don't know why you're laughing you
just i just laughed so hard it hurt my
ribs i had the best night of my life
even though my day had fallen over maybe
it was because i went from a big low to
a big high
and i um and i just went every week
after that just became a super comedy
nerd and just um yeah just really got
involved and eventually got on stage
what inspired you to get on the stage
literally i was thinking i can do better
than them yeah and then i started doing
it i was like i can't
it's hard but like with time i pray and
it was like it was in wellington i was
so lucky because flutter concords were
literally on hbo at the time like so it
seemed like it was because fly congress
were from the same club wellington
comedy club yeah so i was like shivers
like
man in two years i'll be in america and
i haven't made it obviously
but you know like it's still like it's
uh yeah comedy's been good to me and it
it is like the opportunities are there
if you if you can like commit to it and
um you get involved because it's yeah
it's yeah it's comedy
i don't know what i'm saying it comedy
is
[Music]
good it is big in your family as well
because your brother paul's a comedian
slash singer yeah your sister is a
comedian comedian he's a funny man yeah
yeah comedian my dad's um accidental
comedian i think every dad is though my
theory is with comedy is that everyone
is funny yeah like honestly you go like
were you funny well
intentionally like was it the class
clown not really i mean especially
nelson goes just some funny dudes there
intentionally unintentionally there's a
guy who would like jump off the roof for
a dollar like that was quite funny but
like probably not like gonna be like a
sustainable career you know i don't know
youtube legend yeah youtube legend but
um like you know like uh everyone's
funny if you like we're all weird like
everyone's weird when you like get into
their life and like see what's going on
behind closed doors we're all a bit
weird and we pretend to be normal yeah
and um so it's like it's comedy in my
mind is just about finding that and
channeling that and everyone has a
unique view on the world and if you just
if you just sometimes are just going for
a walk and you just listen to what your
thoughts are if you just write those
down your phone that can be the start of
a joke and it's not even saying you want
to be funny like some of the best jokes
i've ever written are things that i
i was genuinely angry that there was a
countdown next to another countdown in
nature and i just keep on talking to
people and people like stop talking
about the two countdowns no one cares
and i made a story about it it was one
of my most successful stories in new
zealand today season one and it was just
like that wasn't even a joke i was just
like i want to find out this is annoying
me so why are they so close together
and um and that's comedy man it's just
like i always wish everyone if they want
to give it a go has the opportunity to
give a go and i'm making it sound easier
than it is it's not quite a meritocracy
you need um
you need the ability and this is how my
family became comedians i mean you need
a safety net and we were lucky that like
my dad and mom have you know provided
for us well to the point where
we were able to like bum around as i
said i spent five years at uni doing a
three-year political science degree you
know like i was a bum for quite a few
years and then even then i was able to
take my i got a job in company straight
away but it was paying like
less than the minimum wage for the hours
i was working and stuff and i was able
to do that because i always had my
parents to fall back on and i think
that's a big part of it and that is a
there's a really interesting thing about
like most the people in comedy now are
like it used to be comedy used to be
this real indie thing where it'd be like
richard pryor was like born in a broth
or billy conley is probably from the
tough i don't actually know i just made
it up but i assume this from had like
quite a tough upbringing in scotland and
then you see like comedians now or just
like rich kids whose dad was a tv
producer or something like that you know
like that is that is the sad reality
where it should be a meritocracy but
still um you know kind of like just
having a comfortable upbringing is a
factor you know who is your favorite
comedian my favorite comedian i love
this that's a good question uh oh that's
not a good question i'm just stalling
for time i've got thousands of favorites
uh mitch hedberg maria bamford stuart
lee in the uk a political comedian yeah
um i love dave chappelle he's gone a
little bit off the deep end i don't know
why he always has to have got trans
people
for no
reason um
uh
yeah he's got a bit bit weird of a
couple of dave chappelle's takes now i
just don't kind of agree with his views
his um his takes on domestic violence
are like awful i hear some jokes which
are like yeah the audience is laughing
and i've always thought the only rule in
common is if it's funny but then you're
like if you're using your platform
you're one of the biggest commands in
the world just to be an [ __ ] to woman
you know like why are you doing that why
are you hating on trans people for no
reason and um so i i must say i love
chappelle and i worship him but um you
know his recent specials he's let me
down a little bit you know he's still
hilarious but um yeah but chappelle
chris rock joe seinfeld
yeah i love there's not many people i
don't like but um yeah a few of my
favorites you probably wouldn't know a
lot of them didn't hear mitch hedberg
check him out dmitry martin check him
out they're good one-liner comedians
you'll see them on youtube um
uh yeah they're good value yeah yeah
what do you like in comedy what are you
into
interesting rugby players they're into
like instagrammers and stuff now that's
a good question a couple of my favorites
ricky gervais yeah um legion michael
mcintyre yeah
you know michael mcintyre is funny he's
all right um
uh yeah
no he's sorry
no no no no no no i'm i'm an [ __ ] i
uh i don't mind michael michael he just
had a bad reputation because anyone who
gets big
you get haters for no reason yeah you
know like you realize that it's like
sandy bell oh yeah yeah like sunny bill
like um michael jordan was another one i
used to always root for the utah jazz
because i was sick of jordan winning and
it was like looking back on i was so
lucky and i've always had lebron james
it's like why i'm blessed to live
through michael jordan lebron james i
should be kissing his ass like i kissed
um steven adams's ass but um
uh
gervais has gone off the deep end a bit
though hasn't
he he's again like why are you always
having a good fat people like move on
also you're not that thin yourself mate
i guess that's why he thinks he can make
the joke yeah but um i wish jovace would
just like pull his head in a little bit
the office is legendary though and he
has some good jokes he has some great i
love um uh nelson mandela um 20 years in
prison hasn't reoffended what does that
prove the prison system works
i'm sorry i couldn't even get that joke
out but that is a good that is a good
joke watch duvet do it because he's
better than me
yeah and um and the and the richard face
podcast is gold i shouldn't i i i grew
up loving javas as well sorry sorry i
asked you your opinion and you started
saying it and i started [ __ ] on it
yeah sorry man i'm not a i'm not as deep
into the now do you watch do you watch
much comedy or do you watch studios
sitcoms white lotus i used to watch a
fair bit i haven't had much time to
watch um too many kids and stuff yeah
too many kids what do you watch what do
you watch on tv like honestly at the
moment i hardly watch tv like that's it
i've recently been watching a little bit
of new zealand today oh cheers man one
of the great shows oh i appreciate it
man now but when i am watching tv at the
moment it's it's rugby or sport pretty
much and it's only after i don't watch
any tv during the day or at most nights
on editing podcast do you think there's
too much do you think there's too much
sport now
to keep people interested no no no like
i mean like my life is all sport so for
example we went um
uh
premier league football into uh
champions league finals into nba
playoffs into um european championships
into the olympics into the nba finals
yeah like i've just been watching sports
for like two months straight it's like
i've gone insane yeah do you find you
watch sport other than rugby or you just
watch rugby no i'll watch all the other
sports it's mental right yeah so
but i mean if you're not watching sport
what else yeah what else you're watching
today
no but like do you think we're wasting
our lives though on sport or yeah mate i
think we waste our lives in general like
if
it's not if it's not sport it's it's
gaming or it's um what else are you like
what else are you doing social media
we're gonna get to that point when we're
like 50 years old and we're like what is
life yeah and then you just you fall
apart then you lose your mind yeah
because you do need some time to be not
doing something or just relaxing or
chilling out and whatever i'm a comedian
that's all i do all i do i'm like a
hedonist so all i do is just chase
pleasure all the time it's like what
there's no way to live your life you
need some discipline or some hardship or
some structure you know and it's like
what am i doing like what is i look i
watch a few youtube videos here we go
and the earth is flat now um i watched
youtube videos about like the purpose of
life and it's help others
and i'm like [ __ ] that
now um no i want to i want to help
others but um i haven't i haven't i'm
still helping myself at the moment
still selfish hey mate one thing i do
want to talk about is your um interview
your tv interview as a whaler yes that
is oh that is my first tv appearance i
think yeah so talk how did you get how
did you get into that well people did
people you got to explain you i don't
want to tell you how to do your job but
you've got to if people won't know what
you're talking about i don't really know
what the situation was but you were on
the breakfast morning show you came on
as a
uh you were a whaling uh lobbyist trying
to encourage
whale farming in new zealand that's why
that's why i didn't have a crack at it
because i wouldn't have got that yeah
yeah yeah so what happened was we had a
segment i was on i started as i said
like first year i just worked behind the
scenes on um jono's show in the second
year they're like hey guy you can have
more responsibility because you're not a
complete idiot and so they put me in
charge of the segment where it was just
like basically just trying to get jono
on tv yeah but this is kind of evil from
me i just tried to get myself on tv the
idea was to try and get on so i was
behind the scenes i thought the
production person trying to help jono
um like for example we would do like um
weird auctions on trade me hoping that
the news would talk about not the news
but like breakfast television would talk
about it yeah so for example you don't
believe it was real but like i put i
went on um trademe and enlisted a harry
potter invisibility cl invisible cape
yeah like the typo being that's just
nothing and you know like they'd talk
about that on breakfast and i'd be like
oh you know would laugh about it back in
the studio or whatever and then um so we
decided i was like do you know what my
dream is my dream is to get on breakfast
tv and do an interview yeah and um the
idea was to get jono on in in like um
makeup but then uh we couldn't afford
the makeup so like guy can just do it
instead and basically my concept was i
was like
anyone who does
it's the way the news media works and i
think there's a lot of good journalists
out there i hate when people go oh
journalists or if or something like that
because they're not always but like
because of 24-hour tv news and clickbait
and stuff they do gravitate towards [ __ ]
stories you know like they'll just see
trash and just put it up you know one
person will have a crazy opinion and
they'll just put it up and act like it's
everyone's opinion it's not yeah and um
so what i did is i just start weird
petitions and i did a couple but the one
i i knew would hit is whaling in japan
was a big idea at the time
and um so i was like why don't we bring
whaling to new zealand because we can
make the meat and um because we're a lot
of whales here and we can send it to
japan and we'll make it be a huge export
for the country right and because i
spent five years at university bumming
around i met a lot of like um
libertarian like right-wing right-wing
sounds weird now make some not racist
people just people who are like the free
market will determine everything those
guys you know like no taxes kind of guys
and um i spoke to some of them and they
would just think any problem could be
solved by business yeah so we're running
out of whales we'll just start a whale
farm and then you can just farm the
whales and you have unlimited whales we
have a shortage of chickens while we
have a shortage of whales and of course
you can't farm whales
but i decided to start a website you
know it's two to two days start a
website called commercial whaling new
zealand put the website up two days
later the sunday news called me not a
very reputable newspaper i like did an
interview on the phone changed my voice
a little bit
they they then put that in the paper and
then this is how the cycle happens and
then the breakfast tv saw that and then
just asked me for an interview i got
picked up
in like a corporate cab driven to the
new studios
um i i talked to the prime minister who
was in the green rooms in new zealand
hey prime minister how you going mate
and um i was still in character though
so i had to talk to john key at the time
i had to talk to him about um
uh
about whaling i've never been a john key
fan really a to his politics but he was
so good man because i'm a nutter i'm
coming coming up to him and going hey
man we need to get whaling off the
ground new zealand and he uh he handled
me so well i was very impressed at how
well he was like well we need to look at
that we need to grow business you know
here like such a diplomatic art i was
impressed how he dealt with me
and then i just like walked into the
studio it was the craziest thing because
there wasn't even many people in there
there was like um no cameras there was
like no no cameramen i think they had
like robot cameras oh yeah so just me
and paul henry in this like black room
talking about whale farming and it was
just like i was just i was pissing
myself just thinking any moment he's
gonna go you're a liar why'd you make
this up this is not funny
but no i just did the whole interview
just talking about whale farms it was
insane and i gave him a i made a cap and
i gave him some merchandise and stuff
like that and then i left it and and and
nothing happened it was the weirdest it
was the
it just shows the standard of like
television like no one checked me
background checked me paul henry
couldn't see through it at all you know
and then um and then i thought i'd
failed and then the next day like
eventually someone was like hey that's
not that's not a pro-whaling activist
that's a guy i saw on stage doing
standard a few weeks ago
who what's he doing there and then it
was like front page news it was like a
big deal yeah because paul henry was a
big deal at the time and like yeah it
was he didn't get tricked he got he did
the whole interview talking to me about
whale farming like it was a real thing
it was so stupid
and uh yeah that literally started my
career so i was stuck with that and how
did you feel in that interview it must
have been awkward yeah yeah yeah yeah
well i was just sure he was just going
you know how you just like you idolize
people you think oh paul henry's so
smart and of course he's just a normal
dude he was a bit of an idiot really and
just couldn't
for some reason couldn't bum me out or
catch me out at all like even just basic
questions like how are you gonna
know which whale is yours you know
you're like oh you killed my wife or are
you gonna tag her how are you gonna
catch you like there's so many elements
to whale farming
whales like move huge around the ocean
like are you going to build a cage for
them like what is the logic here and
like i don't know maybe put them in lake
taupo i have a fresh water
like whale i don't know i'm just i'm
i'm back on the idea now i'm like let's
get this happening it's a good idea new
zealand today yeah launch your whale
farm yeah yeah oh mate how good yeah
and another thing that you spoke about
at the start of the podcast was your um
interview with the mob yeah mongrel mob
one of the great interviews of all time
yeah yeah talk about um being
intimidated or awkward in that wailing
interview but how were you feeling in
that interview with the mob sorry man
you're trying to um you're trying to
wrap this up and i've got so much to
talk about and i i can't do a short
wooden answer i mean the short answer is
i'm not trying to wrap it up go oh i'm
trying to wrap this up then
um okay uh the first thing i want to say
is that um the short answer is um
awkward how second thing is i've got a
lot of flack for that interview for um
for multiple reasons um one is that like
glamorizing or normalizing the mongrel
mob like you know like a gang in new
zealand and two is that um
one of the people behind that group was
accused of a very serious crime um i
don't know i hope that's going to the
police i'm not sure what's going on
there yeah but um basically what the
story is is we background checks
they're right the mongrel was running a
healthy eating facebook page
which is already funny because if the
manga mob want to help the community
that doesn't seem like the most obvious
way they could help the community
there's probably some other activities
they could stop doing that would
probably be better than um writing a
health eating facebook page but the
logic was actually good like it's like
new zealanders need to eat healthier and
eat less takeaways so like all it all
makes sense so i was like this is
hilarious what are we going to do so we
background checked one guy obviously not
all of them we found this guy coe the
rogue
who was a real character and um
uh and we found out like we looked at
his like criminal record and stuff like
that and we're like he's got very
serious assault charges against he's
been in jail for 10 years he chopped
another gang member's finger off in a
brawl we had a machete it's crazy but
anyway we're like we're going to we're
going to go and interview him and the re
the reason i wanted to do it for many
reasons one is that i knew it would be
very successful because new zealand is
like fascinated by the mob and why
shouldn't we be but also because i grew
up in nelson where we didn't really have
gangs like there was a motorcycle gang
paired down by the park near um
kind of with burger king no no we're um
we're where trafalgar seemed to used to
be behind the warehouse kind of thing
yeah yeah yeah there was a gang pad
there but that was like a motorbike gang
that was they're kind of more like a
cosplay of a gang than a real gang i
think i remember they look they they
raided them once and they had a few
rusty old like rocket launchers or
something like they weren't they're like
almost like a joke gang than a real gang
but like when i moved to the north
island
i quickly understood that gangs are big
in new zealand like um you go to the
luge in rotorua i love the luge i lose
24 7. but they'd be like the gang
members just having a birthday party
there full full like
red everywhere and stuff like that and
just blow my mind and with new zealand
today i'd run into all the time i went
to be black power members in a story
about blackface again some of the
funniest guys i've interviewed as well
and what i realized that gangs are
everywhere in new zealand and they're
part of society in a major way and i
feel like we don't talk about it in the
right way because everyone's like we'll
be tough on gangs totally right totally
we've got to be tough on gangs we've got
to stop um any uh organization that's
acting in a criminal way or like
affecting society negatively
but what's really interesting is how we
talk about gangs and stuff how we treat
them is f is messed up because first of
all
we kind of like um use it to like
racially discriminate against people of
color but also most importantly the way
we're tough on gangs i think probably
breeds gangs like one of the discussions
we had with the gang members we had two
things that really struck out from me
one was that
going to jail almost makes you more of a
gang member like almost like recruiter
gang like he was like i was kind of like
involved and i got really involved when
i went to jail for the first time yeah
because i wanted to be for security in
jail and to be and for the privileges
that provide you so that blew my mind
and the second thing was i asked if
because they had young kids as well and
the kids were two years old and they're
doing gang signs and saying sick hail it
was cra it blew my mind i just never in
million years experienced this
and i was like do you want your kids to
grow up and be in the gang and they were
like no and that just blew my mind and i
was like um that's crazy and i was like
and then like they probably will be
because where we live
there's not many other things to do but
i quickly realized and i'm not condoning
gangs or game behavior or anything like
that but i quickly realized that like in
my mind and i need to do more research
on it we're not approaching gangs in the
right way and being tough on them sure
you can put every gang member in jail i
think that will probably just help the
gangs grow stronger like yeah i don't
think the solutions are as obvious as
people think they are and um
and what i also learned is that gangs
and especially in places like gisborne
are like everyone are interviewed no
matter what ethnicity they were no
matter where they were from what
neighborhood they lived in had some sort
of connection to a gang as well and i
got a friend i was talking to a friend
um
uh from a small town in the north on the
other day i was like yeah some of my
best friends are gang members and it's
weird because they're gang members and
they're also dads and they're driving
their cat kids to swing swimming and
stuff like that it's really so the whole
thing anyway it's i'm out of my depth
but
i want to talk about gangs more in new
zealand and i don't have the answers and
i'm not going to be the one to fix it
i'm far from it but i was like
gangs
it's a lot more of a difficult situation
than people think it is and so when it
annoys me when you see clickbait
headlines you know that at the moment
the government's giving money to gangs
to fight meth which seems
counter-intuitive because you assume
gangs are providing the myth as well but
a lot of these are ex-gang members who
know
how to effectively reach out to some
people who have been in gangs and so
like experts have looked at then gone
this is the best way to do it and if an
ex-gang member is trying to get other
people off meth i think that's a good
thing and like probably is the right you
know like you've got to kind of go to
trust the experts a little bit on this
not always but like like you've got and
um so yeah the way
sorry you probably want to laugh
interview about the guy with swastika
tattoos on his face but um but uh yeah
it's just it blows my mind and i just
want to talk about gangs more basically
yeah that is good
yeah so anyway talking to the gang
member was scary as [ __ ] and i thought i
was gonna die we had a safe word but it
was fine um what i learned from him
you had a safe word we had a safe word
what
with him we had a word that like our
production guy would text um our bosses
every so often to uh make sure we were
okay like you know like he had to text
every 10 minutes because we're shooting
with them for hours takes every 10
minutes um umbrella or whatever yeah um
it looks especially if they looked at
our phones and they saw umbrella text
500 times you're like that's clearly a
safe word of some description but we're
texting texting texting to make sure
we're okay and i never felt um
there's a few times i'm not used to
gangs so i just didn't know but like
they just live in a normal community and
just everyone on the street is a gang
member and stuff like that and they'll
treat each other normally and they all
yeah so
so when a gang member would come across
to say hi and then they'll just walk
through our interview and stuff i would
be like this guy's gonna come tell us
off you know and i was like so scared
he's gonna go get the [ __ ] out of here
right now yesterday and get right in the
van and run away
but um uh yeah so we're pissing myself
the whole time absolutely myself but
cody the rogue
reminded me so much myself he was just
like we're basically the same age
um
we just come from completely different
backgrounds so much of yourself yeah
yeah honestly no no honestly with the
same age with the same sort of like
idiot yeah but just when i grew up and i
left high school i had every opportunity
you know i could have gone to any
university i wanted i could have
traveled to any country i wanted um i
could have done anything i wanted and
with him it was the opposite it was like
so few options it's not surprising that
he joined you know like
you know as a man you want to feel like
a provider and a tough guy it's not
surprising someone gets involved in a
gang yeah um i've now learned more about
it i've read up on um
face tattoos and i i i laughed a lot
about swastika face said who's weird
like it's one of probably the highlights
of my comedy career that i got the
courage i want to do this joke
which was um
he goes every tattoo on my i go what's
up with the swastika face tattoos and
here's like every tattoo is from a
different time my life and i said what
time was that was it world war ii
and i'm so proud of that joke but i was
so scared because what happened is he
went silent
he went silent and he was like and i'm
like oh uh uh i was quite a way away so
i could have run because i probably
fastened him but he then he goes um he
just cracked up i don't want to do it to
the microphone but he's just like
but it was like a scary laugh like it
was like not natural it was like really
intense and i was like okay i'm gonna
get murdered now
and um but no like um
uh yeah it was fine and uh but i've i've
since learned that um
i don't know like
i can't speak for koei but like people
get face tattoos for
a whole whole a whole range of reasons
but um just to be intimidating you you
got to ask yourself why does someone
want to be that scary why does someone
put swastikas on their face
and um yeah i i developed a lot of
sympathy for koei um and uh yeah i i do
also i really
um enjoyed a lot by him and as i said
saw myself and him and um i hope he's
going well now and um
yeah he's
he's probably still in the gang but um
yeah
yeah i should reconnect with koei
because um yeah that was one of the most
successful things i've ever done and uh
it was good but yeah i think most people
who criticize me for doing that as well
i understand where they're coming from
as well
and it produced the greatest comedy song
of all time which is married to the mom
very sexist song
uh but very funny song and it's so
poetic because have you heard the song
yeah yeah yeah and it's like um down on
your knees yeah
yeah when you're married to the mob it's
a full-time job
the idea of a full-time job is so funny
to me because it's like no part-time
hours available
you said you couldn't sing oh yeah an
amazing boy no i can't i can't sing
properly um but marriage to the mob is
like a it sounds like a sea shanty or
like a musical song it's like quite a
quite a funny song so um i love that
song married to the mob
uh and and i think he genuinely is like
a really funny interesting guy it's just
you know a shame the the path he um his
his life has gone down but um yeah he's
he's a musical talent and a real
character and uh yeah that was one of
the greatest interviews i've ever done
mate good and i survived into new
zealand gangs and yeah yeah well i mean
read a book to do more research to me i
think uh someone savage just released a
good book about it um the guys love not
the rapper no no
no no no
no i think the guys last time the two
good books about new zealand gangs have
just come out and i've bought them and
haven't read them yet but um gangs in
new zealand are fascinating and they are
um something we need to
fight but i think the fight is probably
um
in my mind it's just the way i see the
world man through economics i think it's
economic and i'm like get if you look at
where gangs thrive it's normally like
areas with depressed economic
opportunity yeah like one of the reasons
it doesn't thrive in nelson or partly
because nelson's a bunch of old people
it's going to be a very grover nelson i
thought grey power was a gang i thought
it was black power white power grey
power it's literally what i thought and
um grey power not a gang it's an old
folks association i found out but nelson
had the biggest one in the country so um
yeah but one of the reasons nelson
probably didn't have many gangs because
it's it's a rich area like it's like how
you know like we don't we do we still
have a lot of issues and gangs probably
became more of an issue but um you know
like we it's just not kind of as
prevalent as it is in a poorer town in
new zealand yeah
how good is that anyway how good's that
is how um kiwi blokes just wrap up any
conversation hey i feel you i feel you
you don't know how to wrap it up just
gotta go how good mate oh i'll let you
get on with it
mate cheers man as always we've gone to
our instagram for some questions and oh
wow okay this is what we do thanks so
much for having me on the pod though i'm
stoked to be the first i know you've had
my boy james malcolm he's also i went to
school with him shout out to james alex
dammit
my boy my close personal friend now i do
i i i i went to school with alex and
grew up with alex so uh
i haven't seen him in 20 years so
forgive me
yeah far out i hope james is doing well
but i'm stoked to be on the podcast oh
mate it's great to have you on okay a
lot of these we've covered already
obviously we've
we've gone through a fair bit oh this is
a good one oh how much how many insults
do they get any insults on the
dicks oh that's good a lot of people
greatest comedian in new zealand oh yeah
you're just ripping these from your own
from your own world okay with a question
with a question okay first one how
scared were you when you asked david tua
about sonny bill williams and his old
lady yeah that was the most scared i've
ever been i did not learn there was a
white guy learning cultural differences
i didn't realize because at nelson
college we said like your mum jokes
quite a bit right not like your mama but
like you know like it was like you know
like um i if your mum was a quite a
common gag
which yeah was it
don't hang me out to dry here anyway in
my circle of friends it was
yeah yeah no it wasn't there was a gag
everywhere fight anyway the point is the
point is i didn't realize and uh i think
david was someone uh i'm not sure yeah i
think someone in someone culture your
mum is sacred it's like the one thing
you don't make fun of right yeah right
so um i did not realize that so he
thought i was just trying to say your
mum a joke and he thought i was taking a
disrespect and my joke wasn't even that
my joke was trying to organize a fight
with sonny bill was a joker sonny bill
was boxing at the time and everyone
wanted to see it was happening so i
tried to get it started like boxers do
anyway
oh i was oh i honestly i think that's
the closest i've come to like i mean
it's a cliche
uh i didn't think it was real until then
i don't think that you know when people
go i almost pissed myself or almost um
you know [ __ ] my pants i didn't think
that was real until that time where i
was like actually i like like basically
was losing control of my balls and it
wasn't even it looks worse on tv because
in real life i was so far away from it
as well but i was like i don't know how
fast he is
he could charge to the cameras and just
like one punch i would die i would he
would kill me and i'd be dead um so yeah
and he was nice after i apologized he
was nice to me and um he did some more
jokes and stuff like that but um yeah
that was my first i had worse jokes than
that as well by the way that was my
first one i was going to get worse oh
wow so i was like i like i got my first
one and then just left i was like that's
that's today's work over thank you very
much yeah what was it to go apologize to
that must have been tough as well yeah
um oh the guy stephen mciver or the
boxing commentator he like brokered the
deal oh yeah that's happened quite a few
times it was um a few sports channels
have been really good to me eh um yeah
who's the other guy uh
oh my god i've forgotten his name he's
the best guys well the rugby guy um he
also did the olympics this year he's
moved to tvnz
scottie stevenson he launched my career
when i first signed to sonny bill he was
the i was at a press conference or so
nervous he knew i had a novelty question
or whatever and he knew i was going to
chicken out and he literally like um
gave me a nudge goes go now go now and
he was the one he like launched so i was
like thanks to those guys for like yeah
you know helping me out so shout out to
scotty stevenson absolutely he's a he's
a great guy i love that guy so you
you're still feeling incredibly
uncomfortable before you've got to do
something like that you're not you're
not naturally that confident to just no
i'm comfortable no and the reason is
it's changed it's not i don't really
care about myself anymore i've done so
many humiliating things i've been to
rock bottom you can't get any lower than
like you know as i said bombing in front
of 100 people and a stand-up gig so um
[Music]
what i do feel bad about is ruining
other people's day or person people and
it happens in new zealand today you know
like whether it be i offend an old man
who's like really religious or something
like that yeah i don't care like i don't
really i kind of think he's full of crap
but at the same time i don't want to
ruin his day yeah and i've done that a
few times and i feel bad about that so
it's the same it's like when i'm singing
to sonny bill i want to do it i want to
get the joke but i also don't want to
ruin sonny bill's reputation japan i
don't want the japanese people to think
that he brought me over he has nothing
to do with me you know you know stuff
like that so um yeah it's more pissing
off the other people than it is pissing
off myself and it's yeah you got to be
pretty careful with the
comedic content don't you yeah a little
bit i mean it's a common thing i don't
think you really do um people now are
like terrified of cancer culture and
stuff like that but i think i've got a
pretty good idea of um where the line is
and when people say don't do a joke you
can do any joke you want it's just like
you are going to upset some people so
you just got to know like is it worth it
something like that rest verse reward
yeah yeah yeah and now we've kind of
learned like hey it's it's it's
it's not cool to like joke about
people's disabilities or something like
that you know like you just learn things
as you go on you're like okay i'll stop
doing that that makes sense yeah and i
just see it as a challenge to find new
ways to be um offensive and shocking
there's there's other ways you can do it
man just um you can't you don't have to
be a misogynist or a sexist anymore
there's other things you can do in the
world you know branch out there's plenty
of exciting um frontiers to explore you
know oh i can't wait to get a woman on a
female on what a lad
i feel like i'm really you'll be like
you'll be breaking the glass ceiling
i'll be so proud of you when you do that
after 100 episodes
yeah okay talked about your rugby career
um does guy enjoy drum and bass no no
how does new zealand do you enjoy
driving bass
i wouldn't be my choice of music no it's
we're in new zealand it's big right
yeah i guess i'm not into drugs i assume
you have to if you're on drugs the
lights and the music and you're just
like whoa
that must be it i think yeah now i like
pretty much every type of music but i'd
say joe and bass and trance and like
stuff the americans that grew up in
nelson like i can't listen to like um i
love those bands just because like
munters would play in nelson growing up
so i kind of got put off that but um i'm
mainly into i'd say hip hop and pop is
mainly what i'm into but um
classic classic rock yeah i don't know
um but yeah definitely no drum and bass
unfortunately a good classical over drum
bass i like classical fair enough okay
shittest town in new zealand and why
granite
granity's not [ __ ] granite is paradise
on earth
if you have a job that you can do from
anywhere go buy a house and granny for
200 grand and just enjoy the rest of
your life you know like um i mean get
out of town if there's a hurricane or a
flooding or anything like that because
it's going to be happening a lot in the
coming years shittest town in new
zealand
it's a tough one because i i try and
defend towns no i i did a story
defending huntley because like yeah
people just shoot on town that's it's
like just what you mean is just poor
town yeah but i've always hated blenheim
finn's up to the tasman marco but
blenheim i hate blind i'm just old
people drinking wine
no fun there um and oh i'mma do i always
have beef with oramudu they can't
pronounce their name learn the name
pronounce the name of your [ __ ] town and
then stop coming to my gig so drunk that
you can't even understand like
worst crowd i've ever had i had this
joke where i had a heckler brick and the
idea was as a brick and if you're a
heckler i'll brick you with it it was
the joke yeah it's got a heckler brick
and um i had on stage and you had to
laugh about it and stuff like that after
the show someone stole my heckler brick
they stole a brick oh madu what is wrong
with you they have a penguin colony
um where it costs 15 to see the penguins
but the penguins are just outside on the
road for free
wake up it's the worst it's the worst
steampunk isn't a thing
oh i'mma do shittest town in new zealand
they're my rivals
[ __ ] you armadoo
passion today it is passionate it wasn't
korean okay yeah this is the thing about
i know granny's beauty granny's
go to granite west coast and south
island is awesome yeah racist sexist
homophobic like a lot of places to
improve but west coast new zealand is a
good time honestly it's the best the
best okay next one did you actually lose
your virginity in the st joseph's church
yeah
no no i didn't i regret nah it's not
even a yarn man i regret even saying
that eh i feel bad i went to st joseph's
church i was growing up catholic i'm not
a really uh religious at all anymore but
um it was just a bad joke and uh i
regret making it because i would have
hurt the people who you know it's one of
those jokes going too far like everyone
who all the nice people who raised me
and stuff in the church and stuff
feeling bad so i i do i actually um i
might have deleted that from the youtube
video i don't even know it's still there
i i deleted when i asked my piano
teacher if he um had sex with my mom
i i felt bad and um and i was like my
mom doesn't deserve that he doesn't
deserve that you know no one deserves no
one to hear that um but i did feel bad
about it sorry to say i did not have sex
it was more it's supposed to be a joke
about um again see how it gets real i
get real serious real [ __ ] you must find
that weird turning me out you're like
joking joking you're serious the world
is a serious place man um
i just can't get over the catholic
church child sex abuse and i don't know
if it was a problem in my community or
if it was a problem in nelson but it's a
problem a lot of places in new zealand
and all around the world
and it's the church literally one of the
reasons bill cosby people like how's
bill cosby free one of the reasons he's
free is because the statute of
limitations in philadelphia
is
so strict that um you can only uh
prosecute like a sex crime uh for like
five years and then you can't
charge it anymore and one of the reasons
for that being is because the catholic
church because they lobbied the
government so hard because they're quite
powerful so you can't prosecute priests
and that has the knock-on effect that
bill cosby can't be brought to justice
because the catholic church and all
their [ __ ] so um
yeah just i watch movies like spotlight
and stuff like that and i go i hope
and there's a lot of good people in the
catholic church that i really liked and
the priest who uh you know grew up with
me at school and stuff was great and i
hope they were all you know everyone was
great but um yeah the catholic church
freaks me out man and uh i i love i
learned so many great things in that
church but um also um yeah they need to
do more yeah yes sorry it's funny how i
go seriously could you do a story on
that no it's too um it's too far for me
at the moment where i'm at like as i
said i try and i try and touch on issues
and like we've done like blackface and
stuff like that like things but um
uh sexual abuse is probably uh too many
trigger warnings for people uh it's
kind of left to the experts to be honest
like as i said commenting on experts and
experts for sexual abuse and experts for
gangs as well it's probably not really
my place to butt in there so who's the
guy who does the um
he does he does go deep into that stuff
he did the tickle documentary yeah david
ferrier yeah well he he he's different
we're we're kind of like mirror
opposites where he is a journalist who
kind of verges on comedy yeah yeah
because he would go like armageddon he's
like a big uh like
pop culture guy as well he'd go to
armageddon and stuff like that so you
kind of take the piss yeah so he would
he's a journalist who virgin to comedy
yeah and i'm a comedian who virgin to
journalism but we're not really the same
but we're a little bit similar and we
also look similar yeah people often um
the other day in napier uh
a guy was like hey i love that movie
about the tickling man and i was like
thanks man come to my show i taught this
guy coming to my show he thought i was
the guy from the single document she was
like [ __ ] yeah
steven adams also came to my show that
same show i think in napier again i ran
to stephen adams
and um oh it was bad man because i was
like
i did two shows that night because of my
first show sold out so as i'll do
another show sticky show didn't sell out
so i was giving him tickets to like a um
a shitty show in a a small theater and i
felt bad like it wasn't that good a show
and afterwards i spoke to him and i was
like hey he was getting shed on the
paper because he won't play for new
zealand yeah and i was like don't read
about they're talking about you in the
paper man and he was this is after i
said hey i love you man so proud of you
again
uh i was like uh don't uh don't listen
to what they're saying about you in the
papers and he's like what are they
saying about me in the papers and i was
like oh [ __ ] you haven't seen this
nothing but good things man nothing but
good things they were ripping him but
again i now if stephen if he got screwed
over as a kid by basketball new zealand
i can understand why he'd be like nah
stuff you now he's a star you know
didn't he almost have to deny also have
to pay almost like
like millions to cover his contract or
something something ridiculous yeah i
think insurance for any athlete uh who's
on a big contract early on but like he
would have insurance now like all the
australian nba players play for their
country so i think he probably could i
think he's got beef with
barcelona new zealand and i i support
him and i support barton new zealand i
hope they can sort it out one day so he
could play a couple games for the tour
black say um but yeah um yeah
steve adams coming to my that's just
weird because i was like doing material
like isn't it hard to buy a house and
i'm just seeing steven adams they're
going no
my contract is 20 million dollars
ah [ __ ] that must be harder it must be
hard everyone knowing how that you're
rich as well that way he must have so
many dudes from rotorua and [ __ ] going
like uh
hey can i borrow some money like all the
time man
i'm not rich
i'm not no one knows how much i earn but
it's not great money like uh i'm yeah
but uh no and i you know i come from
nelson everyone i grew up with is richer
than me you know like it's weird yeah
okay next question we'll move on uh
okay next question how much do you love
karen karen is an icon like people don't
realize they think she's just like the
angry lady from the 20 wax video but she
is um
genuinely talented i wanna do a podcast
with her maybe i think is the dream that
would be good um because she has opinion
on everything she's very smart she loves
sport yeah huge uh huge sport fan
probably uh probably a huge rugby fan as
well she mainly likes qriket but um
karen is like a savant she's good at
everything a little bit like a little
bit like koei the rogue where i'm like i
see this person and i go this person's
so similar to me
just had the complete office
opportunities like karen out of school
when she's 14. you know um
uh
she she went to i hope she's probably
not my story to tell but um she went to
jail for three tabs of acid when she was
17. wow that's crazy right like even now
you there's no way in new zealand three
times as you'd go to jail you know you'd
probably try and help you out if
anything and it's like she went to jail
for three tabs vests that's full full
noise adult prison as a child basically
and uh her life has just been so crazy
and um you realize that like my life has
been so lucky in comparison i'm like man
there's no reason why she shouldn't be a
comedian as well because she um one of
the funniest people i've ever met
intentionally and unintentionally
obviously like that cool she wasn't
planning on that being comedy but we
just did a live tour and um peele
worshiped her the number of people who
are like hey guy we don't want a photo
with you just with karen humiliating for
me but um i understand as well she's one
of the greatest comedians in new zealand
uh history karen she's a legend so
you've got the new zealand uh on new
zealand new zealand today we did a tour
yeah
how does that work you've got the guys
who've all been on the show yeah just a
couple i had josh and isaac from martin
two boys from um the greatest city in
the world martin and uh i just did an
interview with him we did a rap karen
gave someone twenty wax uh did questions
from the audience just uh just like a
real casual basically like a like a live
podcast in a way and um i just realized
then that karen is like a savant and i
love her and new zealand loves her as
well because she um
she gets uh she gets she gets [ __ ] done
a little bit sexist sometimes she always
refers to how ugly paula bennett is and
you're like karen like you can't oh just
oh god it's like oh yeah just you can't
keep her on track but she's uh she's
she's i love karen yeah she's the best
is that two are still going uh no we
stopped we uh i had a show in wellington
cancelled twice and i was like okay
we'll try again next year yeah um
because of covert i got sick one time so
to get a test and the other time um
because the lockdown happened but um nah
still uh
uh still
hopefully next year we'll go bigger and
better and go to more small towns come
to nelson with uh uh not in new zealand
nelson's not a small town it's a
metropolis right that would be good that
would sell out come to my pool right
come to the playhouse theater out here
playhouse theater
guy williams at the playhouse yeah it's
the dream that would be the dream yeah
um is it nanga from across the oh nanga
absolute legend absolutely jindang if
you don't realize this with nanga a
little bit behind the scenes from that
he cut his foot we got a shot at the end
where we were frolicking naked on a
beach long story if you haven't um if
you haven't seen the clip basically
we're riding the rainbow serpent which
is his penis it makes sense all right
and we rode the rainbow sits at the
fourth dimension to the 24th dimension
and we were in heaven but you know for
filming we didn't actually go to heaven
we just were frolicking on the beach
yeah but we were at golden bay it was
the end of the day we just had to go
shoot the shot real quick
and um
i was like can we get to that beach over
there he's like yeah man just wave
through the water so he said it was a
good idea he's the local i don't know
the ground was like all shellfish it was
like
knives like cutting our feet and his
foot got slashed open and so when you
see us frolicking naked on the beach for
like three seconds he did it with blood
gushing out his feet he's the
the toughest guy i wouldn't be able to
do it i would i would have just i would
have collapsed and um we got him back
there we got the ambulance and he didn't
because he's like knew he's like weird
hippie guy he didn't want to go with the
he didn't want to go to the doctor and
get drugs and get stitched up and stuff
like that and he had his like mate come
and give him uv rays and got some
berries rubbed into it and i was like
golden bay
wake up
bananas yeah again an absolute legend
and again a lovely like he's nuts yeah
well no no i shouldn't say nuts he's um
he's eccentric yeah but i genuinely also
think he's a genius i should you
actually raise a good point when i was
there i regret i didn't buy one of his
works of art
he had like um he does like uv the one
with his penis yeah i'm not doing the
penis so i'm not gonna put that in the
lounge no it seems like yeah so yeah he
had one with his penis out i understand
he drew he drew um he drew a picture of
like jesus going through to god and he
was in there near his dick big dick
anyway
that's not the point the point is that
outside of that room where he was doing
uv like glow-in-the-dark paintings he
just did normal paintings in landscapes
and like um
like portraits of like um indigenous
australian people and stuff and he's
actually like a genius like he's so good
at he does every type of art and he's so
good at all of it and um yeah i want to
buy a painting and now now i'm in the
region i should i actually owe it to him
to go back there and buy something
although last i heard he was like um
protesting outside the hospital because
because they were having
vaccines or modern medicine i don't know
what his problem was but um he's he's
got some weird views but shout out to
nanga all love i love you man and um get
the vaccine please god damn it nanga
okay last question this has been good
but um
one piece of advice you could give any
person
uh
uh
life's a joke feel the vibes um be
be nice to people i'm not always nice to
people so i don't even live to that help
others that was the meaning of life
right help others help others yeah
i don't know if i got good advice should
anyone be taking advice from me i don't
know no i think you might you you're
pretty deep i mean you've had some good
advice throughout the podcast but oh yes
you've been um interviewing a bunch of
brain damage rugby players mates
believe in yourself
love others don't be a dick don't be
racist sexist homophobic or any other
that [ __ ] love you
oh mate the best piece of advice we've
had on
thanks for having me on the pod man i
really appreciate you having on the
coming on the podcast um it's been cool
watching your journey from as a young
nelson college lad watching you go
through um the ranks through all those
successes i've said at the start of the
podcast back at you bro you're the first
uh nelson college boy i saw ever in
super rugby i think as far as i know um
so yeah yeah it's awesome follow you too
and yeah good to have a proper chat man
mate appreciate you coming out to the
maplewood studio and coming on the
podcast what a what a privilege love my
poor mate you're a lad thanks man